[Music]
and unfair punishment news
oh what a minute by who let o ll te yeah
well no I don't cuz every time I had let
the dogs out you [ __ ]
I recently found out ugly [ __ ] yeah
what a Grammy I think for this are real
what is what is the dogs referring to
women women who let the ugly women out
[ __ ] hilarious that's there in the
club party and it's like came in I did
not know that then hella people be
seeing that [ __ ] in the club cuz it was
cute homies
what about like you're in the club is
[ __ ] and then the hot chicks are looking
at them like well is that what happened
this [ __ ] oh [ __ ] this must be it is a
[ __ ] that's I don't like it I didn't
doubt it yeah your friends like oh we're
like my dogs yeah we we're out now can't
stop buzz literally thought it was
canines I picture canine in the music
video is actually yeah yeah it was like
a stampede of doggies yeah they have the
background yeah time they've wrapped
about dogs let the dogs your pervert we
thought about their puppies yeah perfect
that's what they call them don't they
yep exactly
he's never called my tits puppies yeah
because you know yours are brand new you
didn't have it before that's a lot of
animals to have beasts from I don't know
what you're talking about videos I have
no idea what you're talking he's from
that yeah be finessed oh yeah yeah
all right well let's start talking about
your bah-bah-bah loose all right you can
come whatever there you go
I'd [ __ ] them in your school clams you
know what I'm up exactly you're a
perfect rape a headline hey hey hey we
all know who the real pervert is in this
room it's me
don't take that away from me don't take
that away pretty perverted that's true
that's true you might take the crown
I've been lacking all my perversion
these days I was mortified
after her father forced her to cut off
all her hair after she got highlights
for her birthday
oh [ __ ] like shave her head my parents
made me do that [ __ ] too wait did her
mom get her highlights and the mom got
her highlights and heard that's not fair
mom made her that's not fair because one
mom the mom had power too yeah that's
some emotional abuse bro and first the
ball okay highlights are fantastic as a
teenager like if I had dye my hair my
like I had a blue streak and I was like
boy huh why hey cool I had black hair
and it was a bob and then I just had a
stroke because I wanted to go blue but
then my parents would not allow it so I
got the darkest blue I could put it in
there then I would try to hide it my dad
would slit his [ __ ] wig do they have
hair extensions back then cuz I got like
a clip in came to do anything cool yeah
like it was like not a good look like
about like I say I can't I might be
misquoting this but about like I say
like 10 or 12 years ago there was this
crazy where it would just be a clip-on
clip-on Street so you don't have to call
your hair did your natural hair is black
dark brown Oh like my color your hair
looks black dark brown I'm sorry it's
gross oh it's
the cabbages thing the cameras aren't
between us girl like it just it's just
messing with my color okay I may be
colorblind its ass press okay healthy
Khaleesi
it's nice she's pretty she looks like
that's a good job yeah so this is the
before this was prettiest fun oh man
they made her cut all her hair off
that's a highlight what is it good and
that her she looks like she's like 15 16
and your hair is everything you have
nothing else in life to report I know
because when I was 15 and I [ __ ] up my
haircut well you never go to school I
was like I'm gonna school dad and he
beat my ass so [ __ ] hard he's like
you're going to school cuz it's learning
is more important than your [ __ ]
fashion show no fashion show is all
about we couldn't afford highlights so I
had to go to the School of Cosmetology
to get some like student school if you
go to School of Cosmetology they have to
get a certain amount of hours and to get
their license so they'll do it for like
really cheap like 15 bucks 30 bucks so I
got it done there they turned my hair
orange and I was like I can't go to
school like this and then we had to go
we ended up having to go spend more
money to get it done professionally to
fix it so this is after mistake even do
a good job on a haircut stats and
children's services you open this it's
on your body you own it and then someone
takes it from you and it's confusing
because the mom says it's cool and then
that mom was like oh yeah so this is the
step mom and the dad this is when back
in 2015 when she was young that sucks
man it's gonna take forever to grow yeah
that's so sad she glowed up though for a
moment they took it away from her
very inappropriate uh she looks totally
different yeah so this is her mom and
then after the whole after that whole
thing about like cutting her hair off
she took her to go get a wig oh no
wonder
that's nice man I like the mom what an
awesome mom you know what's what are
what are they against highlight sport
just to kind of dabble baby powers again
I know and I gotta say something
sometimes you know I will say this girls
with lighter complexions and they have
darker hair y'all need some highlights
sometimes it has a little texture of the
fuchsia for my family they're very again
like they want you to dress your age
what does that even mean so hold on so
they don't follow trends it doesn't
matter if daisy dukes are in or whatever
it's like if you're 13 they still see
you as this like snot-nosed kid that
doesn't know anything so you should be
dressing like us not those kids like
it's not those kids don't want you to be
provocative do not be long do you want
you to wear overall exactly like like
you should never wear like short tight
like short skirts or like super tight
clothes be sexual I get that for a
protective reason that's what highlights
that looks natural it wasn't like she
was like platinum blonde sex-bomb
goddess yeah cuz I never saw a girl with
like highlights or like whatever in her
hair and like [ __ ] whatever hair like
dreadlocks and go oh that [ __ ] make me
horny I can't speak for those parents I
can only speak for my own parents and
the reason why they wouldn't let me do
it is cuz like you hit like natural hair
is youthful you're gonna mess it up
you're gonna fry it why do you want a
rush looking old like people that how
they know dyeing your hair is because
you have gray hair and that's the only
reason why people die the hair and it
depends on how conservative they are
they are because that to their parents
could mean that's pornstar look
punishment and so yeah police and
Children Services aren't getting honest
right to look ridiculous emotional abuse
or seeing time
I'll be like this listen I'll be cutting
deals just so I can have her in check
the way I want listen you get those
highlights but you ain't go sucked it
Phil you'll at least 1900s a suck dick
to your daughter you'll never see that
fine fine fine fine you could get those
pants but you won't that's what you want
to sell I went through the same thing in
junior high I had bangs and then I dyed
my bangs and I came home and then uh my
dad's like what the [ __ ] you [ __ ]
dieter [ __ ] so he wanted to punish me so
he took me to a barber shop and I got my
head shape and all the hell you got look
even more gangster new supply store so
my mom colored my hair for me Oh what
the kids are doing she [ __ ] different
she never controlled what you at war or
any of that stuff
that you still like you want to save my
pants and malls under crazy control my
mom used to use scare tactics my dad's a
pastor - yeah I'm saying all because you
looked bad for the church if you do it
yeah so he don't want me to send my pass
but the hair colors [ __ ] whatever as far
as long as it wasn't like bright pink or
some [ __ ] you frost your tips type of
[ __ ] I was in decay time it was just it
just changed until I got like a dark
light look like a light like a lighter
brown I thought it was so hot when guys
frosted their tips I thought it was hot
were they yeah they spiked it and they
crumpets I never really did the realest
night yeah my mom would like she would
use scare tactics for like drugs for
hair dye for anything she didn't want me
to do she'd be like you couldn't do it
but just know since your hair is so dark
they'd have to strip away all the color
then you could never get the color back
on that hair then you know it's like
that permanently maybe it grows back
maybe it doesn't that's more like that
would never work on the dozer mom yeah
you should have told her how would you
know cuz your why
you don't know my Asian problems like it
don't watch you don't know where he got
it from I know this okay
she won't know because you do have to
commit though cuz sometimes limited like
if your head really fine in thin and you
color your hair that [ __ ] gets [ __ ] up
and fried and so what happens out the
bag you've got to start straightening it
all the [ __ ] are you sure then for sure
cuz I I would have been [ __ ] up like
dried up like this edge but I thank them
for that I just feel like there's a
different way to go about and they kind
of did that [ __ ] not not to that level
at all where my parents were not
divorced they were together but then I
would ask my dad for permission you'd be
like alright yeah but just ask him on
see what she says and I'm like mom dad
said I could go to this
I know he eat my death would tell me to
tell my mom and then I would say hey dad
said he's okay with it can I go and he's
like no I don't think it's okay with
they go tell your dad this and I'd be
like going back and forth it was so
interesting though because if I saw my
daughter let's say at first I was so
against it right I was like listen I was
wrong watch your [ __ ] cause I looked at
her I was like actually you were pretty
busted before that was good that's cuz
they're sensible yeah I'm like you what
[ __ ] busted ain't nobody want touch
Dom because you already don't want her
to go out with boys but you're making
her more appealing for I'm also an
honest father and I love her and I grew
up in abusive Playstore so my [ __ ]
daughter look like a badass [ __ ]
[ __ ] I gotta say it I'm like oh [ __ ]
girl
[Laughter]
I would have to go to the other room get
the [ __ ] out of my face oh my god
[Laughter]
sweetie our daughter she looks great
[Music]
[Music]